bonsoir et bienvenue dans kiosque votre
émission culturelle pour ouvrir ce
magazine d'abord une pensée évidemment
toute particulière pour les quatre
dessinateurs de Charlie Hebdo tué ce
mercredi à 7 janvier lors d'une
fusillade au sein de leur journal Charb
notamment était native vous le voyez sur
ces images des Yvelines le directeur de
la publication de Charlie Hebdo de son
nom Stéphane charbonnier était né le 21
août 1967 à Conflans-Sainte-Honorine il
y a deux ans il avait déclaré dans une
interview accordée à nos confrères du
monde je préfère mourir debout que vivre
à genoux et puis autre dessinateurs tués
lors de cette attaque Cabu il était venu
en novembre dernier à l'occasion du
festival Blues sur Seine présentait une
exposition autour du jazz je vous
propose de l'écouter toutes nos pensées
vont bien sûr à leur famille à leurs
proches parce qu'ils sont morts au nom
de la liberté de la presse
ça c'est des dessins pour et je dis
toujours que faire des dessins pour
c'est plus difficile que de faire des
dessins contre je fais des dessins
souvent contre les politiques quand ils
déconnent à mon avis mais là je cherche
simplement à
ce que les gens aient envie d'écouter de
la musique sur ses dessins quoi voilà
pas facile comme transition parler de
musique Jacques d'or bonsoir il paraît
que la musique adoucit les mœurs c'est
vrai
il faut espérer il faut espérer surtout
en ce moment alors on va parler de
Chopin avec vous le Chopin on connaît on
connaît notamment les valses nocturne et
dorénavant avec vous on va aussi
connaître ces pièces isolées que vous
avez réunies au sein d'une intégrale
dans un dans un CD alors c'est quoi des
pièces isolées d'abord alors en fait les
pièces isolées on peut dire aussi les
pièces
diverses les pièces ce sont les éditeurs
de partitions qui ont regroupé toutes
les pièces qui n'étaient pas dans les
dans les recueils de valse de nocturnes
d'études ils ont regroupé toutes les
toutes les pièces qui sortaient de ces
cycles là et simplement j'avais remarqué
que au disque il y avait toujours les
intégrales des nocturnes des valves etc
mais il n'avait jamais une intégrale de
ces pièces là or c'est un domaine très
fréquenté Chopin
et donc ça m'a paru une bonne idée de
faire un premier disque Chopin avec avec
ces pièces là voilà il y a combien de
pièces en tout et comment vous avez
réussi à les répertorier c'est facile à
répertorier ce qu'on se dit que c'est
elles sont alors il y en a les 6
premières du disque sont des pièces qui
ont été publiées par Chopin lui-même
donc ça elles sont assez connues même si
par exemple elle est gros de concert qui
est dans le disque est une pièce assez
rarement jouée je ne sais pas pourquoi
et mais par contre il y a 17 petites
pièces posthumes qui ont été publiées
après la mort de Chopin qui sont sortis
peu à peu certaines même après l'an 2000
donc j'allais dire en cherchant dans
plusieurs éditions il y a moyen de les
trouver en partition et puis ben voilà
des enregistrer alors il y a des pièces
de piano qui sont assez longues qui font
plus de 10 minutes et des pièces qui
font 50 secondes
ce particulier non oui alors ben celle
que Chopin a publié était vraiment des
pièces assez longues ce sont les
premières du disque après toutes les
petites choses qu'il a écrites qu'il a
dédicacées parfois une personne
c'était une façon de faire un geste
d'amitié aussi d'écrire une petite page
de musique dans un carnet pour une
comtesse ou ce genre de choses des
petites caisses des circonstances voilà
c'était quelques quelques petites un peu
de poudre d'or semer ça et là et donc
j'ai essayé de trouver un ordre
qui rendent l'ensemble cohérent
l'enchaînement des pièces cohérent parce
que elles sont toutes de nature très
différentes donc c'est ça aussi qui est
très intéressant c'est à partir de
pièces qui ne forment pas un cycle
d'essayer d'en faire un voilà qu'est-ce
que ça évoque Chopin pour un pianiste
c'est pas récent le compositeur dédié au
pianiste
je pense que c'est un compositeur qui
aime beaucoup les pianistes parce que
outre ses immenses qualités musicales
il était lui-même pianiste et
il a vraiment exploité l'instrument
d'une façon tout à fait nouvelle à son
époque et on sent dans la façon dont il
écrit on sent la
celui qui joue sans bien que c'est écrit
pour une main c'est pas penser
seulement sur le papier il y a vraiment
un plaisir physique à jouer à jouer
chopinion
quand même de jouer du Chopin
avec Mozart je pense que ce sont les
deux compositeurs les plus délicats à
interpréter mais une fois surmonter les
difficultés qui qui attendent le
pianiste je pense que c'est aussi parmi
les plus gratifiants aussi
pour ce qu'il renvoie
non c'est
alors on va parler de votre parcours
mais avant d'en parler de regarder un
extrait c'était à Ville-d'Avray en 2010
ça remonte à quelques années
une polonaise de Chopin on vous écoute
voilà on voit que c'est pas toujours
simple Chopin ça va vite c'est non c'est
ça ça va vite ça va lentement
mais elle est jamais gratuite elle est
toujours au service de l'expression
alors si on veut vous entendre il y a un
concert qui sera donné ce samedi soir
laboratoire de Versailles tout à fait
dans ce concert vous on pourra écouter
toutes ces fameuses pièces isolées alors
il y aura la majorité il y aura toutes
les pièces que Chopin à lui-même publié
et il y aura une partie des courtes
pièces qui suivent oui conservatoire de
versa c'est un lieu vous connaissez bien
c'est un retour parce que j'ai fait j'y
ai fait mes études j'ai fait mes
premières études de musique
et
puis j'y ai fait un récital mais déjà il
y a 10 ans donc c'est vraiment
un retour aux sources
du piano est-ce que tout petit on vous a
mis devant un piano parce que vos
parents ont eux-mêmes ou non non ma
grand-mère m'a mis au piano
elle m'a montré m'a fait faire mes
premiers pas mais c'était ça c'est fait
tout seul personne m'a poussé non c'est
plutôt moment où il fallait faire des
choix au moment du collège je me suis
dit non finalement c'est c'est ça que je
veux faire donc je suis rentré au
conservatoire et voilà pourquoi cet
instrument là particulier
assez commun beaucoup de d'enfants
pratiques mais après il faut pouvoir en
faire un métier je sais pas si ça
s'explique une attirance pour un
instrument
qui permet
une façon d'appréhender la musique de
façon orchestrale si on joue de la flûte
s'il y a qu'une seule note qu'on peut
jouer en même temps au piano on peut
tenter de prendre connaissance d'une
pièce d'orchestre qu'on peut on entend
l'accompagnement le chant on entend tous
les toutes les hauteurs possibles donc
c'est un choix incroyable alors ce CD de
Chopin les intégrales des pièces
d'isolées c'est pas votre premier CD
vous avez déjà composé d'autres d'autres
choses avant il y a eu deux autres
disques il y en a eu un premier qui
était un disque dédié à des pièces peut
jouer aussi de Mendelson liste
Tchaïkovski Messian et Bartok sur le
thème de Noël
que Noël est souvent interprété à
l'orgue ou par les chorales mais
rarement au piano et en fait il y a un
répertoire qui existe donc voilà c'était
cette idée là et ensuite
j'ai fait un deuxième disque consacré au
compositeur François Leclerc
donc il y avait des pièces inédites
également enregistré
c'est c'est toujours agréable bon voilà
et ben écoute donc ce qu'on se céder
qu'on peut trouver chez tous les bons
disquaires comme on dit ouais Chopin les
pièces isolées de Jacques d'or et puis
si on veut vous écouter un concert qui
sera donné donc samedi soir au
Conservatoire de Versailles merci
beaucoup d'être venu sur le plateau de
kiosque merci allez on continue cette
émission avec Mitsu c'est un opéra film
un vrai challenge artistique est proposé
le 23 janvier au Théâtre de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines à la recherche
du temps perdu vous allez tout
comprendre avec Jean-charles Fitoussi et
Claire Mélanie simubert
un orchestre un film des acteurs doublé
par des chanteurs c'est le principe d'un
opéra film un concept novateur proposait
le 23 janvier sur la scène du théâtre de
50 ans en Yvelines aux manettes un duo
d'artistes qui a travaillé pendant une
année lui et réalisateur elle et
musicienne ils ont d'abord réalisé un
film autour du thème d'une lettre de
ring que au peintre Balthus avant de
passer à la conception musicale tout un
challenge
on a tourné un film en sachant que ça
allait être mis en musique et surtout
que les les acteurs du film allait être
doublé par les chanteurs d'opéra
et du coup on a tourné le film d'une
manière un peu différente de celle que
nous aurions utilisé si on avait tourné
un film normal c'est à dire que je
dirigeais les acteurs de telle sorte que
la compositrice puisse ensuite écrire sa
musique qui s'articulerait avec les
paroles des acteurs parfois on leur
faisait des prises plus lentes plus
rapides pour quel est le un peu plus le
choix disons du tempo de sa musique
le compositeur est tout le temps face à
des contraintes et heureusement pour lui
parce que sinon n'a pas le le le
l'aspect infini des possibles et
vertigineux donc je dirais elle a
évidemment la contrainte on la
connaissait puisqu'on avait choisi ce
dispositif ensemble
et que du coup au contraire j'étais très
contente de savoir que j'allais avoir
une contrainte je ne savais pas comment
j'allais m'en dépêtrer il a fallu
choisir les prises et ensuite relever
les rythmiques qui à partir de là
complètement imaginé la musique qui
allait accompagné ça les notes qu'elle
allait être chanter le travail donc de
près d'une année à découvrir le 23
janvier vous pourrez y suivre le
parcours d'un enfant qui en cherchant
son chat Mitsu trouve la porte du temps
si en gouffre pour mieux retrouver son
animal de compagnie un conte plein de
magie qui dure une heure environ avoir
en famille
allez nous restons dans le domaine de la
musique et cette semaine Nicolas Gervais
dans sa chronique nous propose de
rencontrer Isabelle Olivier c'est une
artiste elle sera en concert à la ferme
de blédard à Guyancourt
fameuse harpiste ouverte aux sonorités
jazz elle présente un projet d'opéra
avec des musiciens français et
américains un projet adapté du baron de
perché dit à l'eau Calvino pour nous
parler de cette hymne à la liberté qui
sera présentée le 17 janvier à la ferme
de bel-eba avant une forme plus légère
en mars à la Maison de la Poésie voici
Isabelle Olivier dans le kiosque
c'est un livre dit Talo Calvino qui
s'appelle le Baron Perché je l'ai lu
quand j'avais 11 12 ans et c'est vrai
que c'est un livre qui m'a accompagné à
différentes étapes de ma vie et qu'à
chaque étape de Belgique finalement je
voyais le même livre mais décliné avec
des on va dire des reliefs différents et
qui m'a toujours amené à des réflexions
profondes quelque chose de très
philosophique qui est le droit à la
différence qui est qu'est-ce que c'est
que d'être libre
qu'est-ce que c'est que on va dire vivre
en harmonie avec la nature qu'est-ce que
c'est que être en harmonie avec les
hommes et ce jeune garçon de 11 12 ans
qui dit non à un place d'escargot
d'escargots va avoir cette envie de
vivre dans un arbre et de plus jamais
revenir sur Terre à travers cette fable
finalement se déroule une partie de
l'humanité qui est totalement
contemporaine
mon album précédent était une
déclinaison de chansons quand je suis
arrivée à la fin de ses chansons j'avais
envie de partir sur une histoire
construite et la notion d'opéra jazz m'a
vraiment piqué de curiosité et de
passion et d'envie et effectivement
cette histoire-là se prête extrêmement
bien au jazz parce que ce jeune homme
qui part vivre seul dans son arbre
quelque part improvise sa vie mais en
même temps en ayant cette capacité de
d'innover et que quelque part pour moi
le jazz c'est un peu ça c'est cet esprit
libre et d'innover à partir d'une
tradition musicale qui à la fois la
tradition européenne de Debussy de Ravel
de tous ces grands maîtres et aussi de
ce qu'a apporté les États-Unis sur le
rythme
et aussi pour ça que j'ai eu envie et
l'idée de faire un projet
franco-américain c'est d'avoir une
équipe américaine une équipe française
et de relier les deux
2014 c'était de travailler vraiment sur
les instruments contre base batterie
harpe et électronique donc la nature
pour moi se représentait avec des sons
et de décliner au fur et à mesure des
quatre saisons des enregistrements en
France et aux États-Unis sur cette
thématique des saisons et d'empreintes
de la nature et aussi des hommes donc
par exemple en hiver ça peut être un feu
de cheminée ici et ça peut être les
craquements de la glace à Chicago
c'était un challenge de les intégrer
dans la partition musicale mais le fait
qu'il y ait pas de mots ça m'a laissé on
va dire un champ complètement libre sur
l'imaginaire et la créativité donc la
deuxième année avec le projet qui va se
concrétiser à la ferme de Bel et bas en
janvier c'est 4 chanteurs de Chicago et
cette musicien français donc là il va y
avoir des textes qui sont en anglais
mais ces textes je les écris avec on va
dire
la nécessité que un enfant qui ne
connaît pas un mot d'anglais doit
comprendre l'histoire
et puis en 2016 effectivement c'est de
rajouter des cœurs et un Big Bang donc
de faire une grande formation pour
finalement on va dire faire le bouquet
final
pour mars on va avoir la chance de faire
une version théâtre et musique avec
Charles Gonzalez qui en résidence à la
Maison de la poésie et donc on sera en
duo il part du texte du Baron Perché il
fait une sélection de texte et puis moi
je les mets en musique avec justement
cette idée d'opéra
top
est instrument s'imagine
jusqu'au bout de la nuit
et le ciel connaît la musique même si
c'est la télé qui est dans ses cornes on
retrouve Catherine sur le plateau du
kiosque
allez passe à la danse maintenant avec
deux rendez-vous à noter donc de la
danse pour le jeune public des neuf ans
avec les Pokémon Crew qui rendent
hommage au cinéma des années 40 et en
parallèle au début du hip-hop c'est
dimanche à 16h à la Meurisse de Trappes
entrée à partir de 8 euros voici un
extrait
et puis autre spectacle de danse et
toujours du hip-hop cette fois au
théâtre de 50 ans en Yvelines avec pixel
un spectacle présenté du 8 au 10 janvier
mise en scène par Moura de Merzouki une
exploration artistique très riche que je
vous propose de découvrir en musique
et du théâtre maintenant avec la tempête
d'après Shakespeare donner ce samedi
soir au prismaël en cours au commande de
cette œuvre à l'impralon société honneur
de la Comédie française il sera
notamment entouré de Dominique Pinon et
de Sarah Biasini tarif à partir de 21
euros voici un extrait de La Tempête de
Shakespeare
seulement pour l'instant que la
généreuse fortune qui maintenant le
sourire
é
prévoir si
qu'une étoile peut mettre favorable
faire décliner mon sang
et comme tous les mercredis la chronique
signifie avec tout d'abord les avis de
spectateurs éclairés au micro dès le
dimanche j'ai pensé que c'était une
fille une réalité d'un bon film parce
que je connaissais cette affaire là
avant et donc je trouvais que c'était
c'est triste comme à faire très bien
très réaliste
bon je connaissais pas du tout l'affaire
c'était sympa tu as un film très prenant
et je suis comme elle mon bouleversée
par ce film là sachant qu'il risque de
libérer en 2020 ça fait un peu peur
c'est un très bon film très bon acteur
ça a bien été filmé mais c'est prenant
mais j'ai passé un moment agréable j'ai
apprécié tous les rôles enfin j'ai
trouvé un film divertissant
avec beaucoup de décorations j'ai trouvé
ça super Vincent Rotier déjà j'adore
donc je suis venu pour lui et tous les
acteurs sont vraiment splendides
vraiment super j'ai trouvé ça assez
extraordinaire très touchant et je
savais pas du tout en fait de quoi ça
parlait enfin j'en avais entendu parler
vite fait mais je connaissais pas
vraiment le sujet du film tout et donc
je trouve ça vraiment super
voilà bah des spectateurs en tout cas
qui ont l'air d'apprécier les films
qu'ils ont vu alors on passe maintenant
au coup de coeur du cinéma du
professionnel pardon du 7e art ce soir
galopino du grenier à celle de Trappes
bonjour et bonne année je voudrais vous
parler d'un autre film coup de cœur de
cette semaine il s'agit du film Chantons
sous la pluie qui est une comédie
musicale sur l'histoire du cinéma il a
été tourné en 1953 en couleur en
technicolor donc des couleurs très très
chatoyantes c'est un film fondateur
puisque il est il était dans 1953 mais
il raconte le début du cinéma parlant
les années 30 avec le cinéma muet et
l'arrivée du parlant c'est l'histoire de
downlo coude et Lina le monde qui sont
deux stars du cinéma muet hollywoodien
et le cinéma parlant arrive et là ils
vont devoir s'adapter et malheureusement
le la voie désagréable de Lina va
menacer le duo et on engage alors Cathy
qui est une danseuse pour
pour doubler la voix de Nina alors c'est
intéressant puisque sur pendant les
passages de tournage de film muet on
voit que sur le même plateau on peut
avoir plusieurs tournages en même temps
puisque le son ne dérange pas on entend
tout le monde qui crie à droite à gauche
mais vu que le son il passe pas c'est
c'est assez intéressant d'avoir ça on a
vraiment l'histoire du cinéma et puis on
a tout le processus de création du film
du film parlant avec les problèmes
techniques qui pouvaient avoir à
l'époque où est-ce qu'on met le micro
comment ça marche est-ce qu'on tourne la
tête est-ce que le micro il prend bien
le son c'est très intéressant c'est
vraiment très beau puis il y a c'est un
film de chant de danse de claquettes
c'est un film sur l'histoire du cinéma
encore une fois qu'il y a deux séances
de ce film là une en version française
une en version originale sous-titrée
vous retrouvez ces séances sur notre
site
www.cinemagrandael.com merci
on se quitte pardon en musique Michel
Fugain et pluribus seront sur la scène
du théâtre espace Coluche de plaisir
vendredi 9 janvier à 21h un spectacle ou
Michel Fugain est accompagné de 12
musiciens bonne semaine à vous gardez
l'esprit ouvert et curieux